Now that you have a chatter feed, let's talk
about publisher actions. Publisher actions allow you to do
things directly in the feed. There are four general
types of actions. Create Actions let users create records.
Log a Call actions let users record the details
of phone calls or other customer interactions. Update actions
let users make changes to a record from the
records feed. Custom actions allow you to create your
own actions programatically, but we won't cover these here. Be
careful about creating too many actions. You really want to just
have the ones that you do most frequently. For example,
which of the following tasks would be good publisher actions?